okay
the nomination goes on the calendar yes
so there's no reporting
good good i just wanna
come on
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
so
[Music]
i ask unanimous consent the quorum be
dispensed with
without objection now madam president
yesterday the senate completed
an extremely productive day by
confirming
three members three members of the
president of president biden's cabinet
today we're going to keep up the pace by
moving the
ball forward on two more of the
president's nominees
first the senate will begin the process
of bringing javier becerra's nomination
to serve as hhs secretary to the floor
this is a critical position as we
continue to battle the virus
and i'm perplexed that my none of my
republican colleagues would vote for him
he's a capable man he's worked hard to
make sure that people get health care
and some have said well he's not a
doctor neither was the previous
trump nominee for hhs who happened to be
a pharmaceutical company executive
what would americans prefer second
the senate will move forward with
another very historic nominee
that makes us so proud rep deb hayland
of new mexico to serve as the next
secretary of the interior
she'll be confirmed on monday repayland
was accepted
was elected to the congress in 2018
she was the first native american woman
along with representative cherise davis
from kansas
to ever ever serve in the people's house
if confirmed repealand would not only
become the first native american to lead
the department of interior
she would be the first native american
to serve in any cabinet position
in american history we've had a vice
president with native american roots
but never a cabinet official given the
long and troubled relationship
between federal government and tribal
nations the ascension of repayland
to the top of the interior department is
a profoundly
important moment for america as we
advance on the long road
still not fully traveled at all of
equality
or towards equality for too long
tribal nations have been denied a seat
at the table
where decisions that were made that
impacted their lives
and their land not only will secretary
hayland ensure that they get a seat
she will bring her own lived experiences
to the table alongside them
under president trump the department of
interior became one of the most scandal
riddled agencies in the history of the
federal government
it gave oil and mining companies carte
blanche to drill in wildlife reserves
roll back environmental protections
and greatly undermine trust in the
federal government and tribal lands
repellent will move the department in a
dramatically different direction
one of her most important
responsibilities will be to restore and
uphold the federal government's
obligation
to sovereign tribal nations i cannot
think of a better candidate
to take on this job than repayland and i
greatly look forward
to confirming her it will be historic
now in general madam president the
senate is making great progress in
installing president biden's highly
qualified nominees
so far we've already confirmed 16
cabinet level appointments
we're set to increase that number to 18
after secretaries heyland and becerra
are approved
every single one of the president's
nominees has been confirmed
with a bipartisan vote here on the
senate floor
president biden deserves to have his
team in place
and the senate is moving quickly to get
the job done
now on the american rescue plan which
finally cleared
the hurdle in congress yesterday by
passing the house
the plan is now only a signature away a
presidential signature from becoming law
soon very soon the most sweeping
recovery effort in recent history
will get underway direct checks will be
delivered to american families from
coast to coast roughly 85 percent of all
households
the american people can expect those 14
100
checks for each person in the family to
be delivered
by the end of march and we're making
amazingly good progress on vaccines
vaccines will be available far more
quickly to far more people
just this morning the biden
administration
announced an expansion of the vaccine
program
and i was able to announce that more
than
100 community health centers in my home
state of new york
will be eligible to get their own
dedicated supply of vaccines
there is a brand new vaccine
supercharged for new york
and for some of the rest of the nation
as well
the trucks more vaccines and more sites
to administer them
over a hundred sites will be set up
across new york state
and administer a massive influx of new
shock supplies
there is light at the end of this
coveted tunnel
which has always been centered on access
to a free back scene
for all new yorkers more access and more
shots means a quicker recovery
and that's what we want and that is
becoming available for my
home state of new york and for the
entire
nation the chc sites community health
center sites
will be federally funded organized by
the department of health and human
services
a huge expansion we have all heard
stories
numerous stories of people having to
travel too far to get the vaccine
hampering our ability to recover and
return to normal
with this announcement of more vaccines
and more new york sites to administer
them
new yorkers have something to celebrate
and i thank the president
for working with us to make this effort
real
and to bring it to every state in the
nation
now other things are happening too our
schools
will receive critical assistance to
update their infrastructure
to hire more teachers and tutors and
prepare
to reopen as fast and as safe as
possible
there's going to be money for broadband
there's going to be dollars
for rural hospitals there's going to be
dollars to help our tribal nations
all who are suffering the new
restaurants act
so important to so many of our states is
becoming law
more money for save our stages to help
our arts institutions
is coming and perhaps the thing that we
are most proud of
although there are so many in this bill
helping people with their pensions
making sure those who are laid off still
get health care by funding cobra fully
so many good things for average working
families
but maybe the most important of all who
knows there's so many good things in
this bill but maybe it's the child tax
credit
which will cut childhood poverty in half
when a child is born into poverty no
fault of his or her own
they don't get adequate nutrition they
don't get adequate health care they
don't get adequate housing they don't
get adequate education
and then when they go into young
adulthood they have nowhere to go
and then they get blamed for their
plight the better
smarter more effective thing to do is
help them get out of poverty early so
they can lead good productive lives
as citizens and as taxpayers we're doing
that for the first time here
and i hope it's something that we can
continue
simply put the american rescue plan
is one of the most significant pieces of
legislation
to pass the congress in recent history
yesterday i started
describing in more detail some of the
lesser-known aspects of the plan
everyone knows the vaccines are coming
the 1400 checks are coming the money for
schools is coming
and now people know of the child tax
credit but there are lots of other
things in this bill
today i want to continue by talking
about another unheralded provision
assistance to native communities a topic
very much on theme today given the
nomination of secretary halen
one of the most tragic features of the
covet 19 pandemic
is how destructive it has been for
america's tribal nations
native americans have faced the highest
risk of infections hospitalizations and
deaths due to covert 19
bar none the highest
early in the crisis the navanojo nation
to take one example saw more cases per
capita
than any other state in the country
decades decades of an unraveling social
safety net declining economic
opportunity an overburdened health
system in the failure of the federal
government to honor its trust
obligations to american tribes
left native communities unequipped
unequipped to handle the crisis
but in the american rescue plan
democrats will deliver the single
largest investment to native programs in
our nation's history
we are very proud of that it is historic
the singest largely investment in native
communities in our nation's history
more than 31.2 billion dollars in direct
funding will go to the tribes and
communities
to defeat this pandemic and rebuild
their communities
20 billion directly to tribal
governments so they can stabilize
essential services six billion to the
indian health service
not just for vaccines and testing and
tracing but to improve and restore
these rural long-laget neglected
hospitals
hundred millions more for native
education
10 million will go to just make sure
communities can access clean water
listen to the items i just mentioned
clean water keeping hospitals running
connecting kids to broadband these are
absolute necessities
and the american rescue plan is going to
dedicate resources to all of them
for indian country i want to thank a
whole bunch of my colleagues so many
contributed
but the chair of the indian affairs
committee senator schatz
senators tester and cantwell and smith
and kellyanne ben ray lujan
heinrich very very important
heinrich particularly pushed for
broadband
so it's a team effort and proud my
colleagues
the american rescue plan takes us a
giant step closer to fulfilling our
trust
responsibilities to all native americans
alaska natives and native hawaiians
this is just one example an important
one how the rescue plan
will dramatically improve the lives of
millions of people
in this great country of ours i yield
the floor
[Music]
the clerk will call the roll
ms baldwin
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
uh
[Music]
[Music]
matter republican leader i was consent
to further proceeds on the quorum call
be defenseless
without objection madam president a year
ago
coronavirus cases were beginning to
climb on u.s soil
shutdown measures were starting to take
effect
americans have endured one of the
strangest and most
painful years in living memory
nearly 2 million americans have been
hospitalized with serious cases
of the virus more than a half a million
have lost their lives millions of
students and workers
have had their lives completely thrown
off course
these dark times have also spotlighted
some of the best of america
heroism selflessness ingenuity
last march tonight we passed the cares
act without a single dissenting vote i
said we'd see a new generation of
american heroes
and so we have doctors and nurses and
first responders have worked tirelessly
to help
their fellow americans essential workers
kept banning their posts
and prevented economic collapse
neighbors looked out for neighbors and
small businesses shifted
gears almost overnight
children and parents have fought to
adapt to
extraordinary disruptions
and incredible heroes from lab coats in
america
and worldwide worked at light speed to
decode this new enemy
and create life-saving vaccines in
record time
today together we're standing on the
cusp of a new springtime for our country
not like anything we've experienced in
our lifetimes
more than 95 million vaccine doses have
reached american arms
another 2 million every single day
covert related deaths have plummeted now
less than half of their high
particularly for the elderly and the
vulnerable
science reaffirms kids can be safely in
the classroom
right now states are starting to lift
blanket restrictions freeing citizens
and small businesses to follow smart
precautions themselves
and for weeks every indicator has
suggested our economy is
poised to come roaring back with more
job openings for americans
who need work none of these trends
began on january 20th president biden
and his democratic government
inherited a tide that had already begun
to turn
toward decisive victory in 2020 congress
passed five historic bipartisan bills to
save our health system
and protect our economic foundations and
fund operation warp speed
to find vaccines senate republicans
led the bipartisan careers act that got
our country through
the last year the american people
already built a parade
that's been marching toward victory
democrats just want to sprint in front
of the parade
and claim credit so when 10 republican
senators went to the white house to
suggest working together
a democrat said uh no both the
democratic leader and the white house
chief of staff now indicate
they think president obama's problem was
that he was too bipartisan
this time as one journalist put it the
situation was quote
democrats to gop take it or leave it
end quote the it
that we're talking about here was a bill
that only spent about one percent
on vaccines and about nine percent on
the entire
health fight the rest of the tab went to
things
like this a 350 billion dollar bailout
for state and local budgets
unrelated to pandemic needs with strings
attached to stop states from cutting
taxes on their own citizens down the
road
take the money you don't get to cut
taxes
massive federal school funding spread
over several years without requiring
quick reopening sweeping new government
benefit network requirements
whatsoever a time warp to the bad times
before bipartisan welfare reform
which democrats are saying they want to
make
an agricultural assistance condition not
on specific financial need
but solely on the demographics of the
farmer
which some liberal activists are
celebrating as
reparations only about 20 percent of the
spending went
to 1400 direct checks to try to
and keep all of the unrelated socialism
out of the spotlight this wasn't a bill
to finish off the pandemic it was a
multi-trillion dollar trojan horse full
of bad
old liberal ideas president biden's own
staff
keep calling this legislation quote the
most progressive
bill in american history hardly the
common sense baptism
promised let's pause today
on your mark to remember
and tomorrow but we also look for
growthism
to the future 2021 is to be
a historic comeback year not thought
of the left legislation was passed after
the tide had already turned
but because of the resilience of the
american people
now mr president on a completely
different matter at noon today
the senate will vote on whether to pluck
the bersera nomination out of committee
after it failed to garner enough support
to advance
every one of president biden's
nominations the senate has considered
so far has received bipartisan support
for confirmation there's a reason mr
becerra could not get one single
republican vote to move out of committee
it's because he's such a thoroughly
partisan actor with so little subject
matter expertise in such a demonstrated
history of hostility toward basic values
like the freedom
of science of conscience the freedom of
conscience
there's nothing about mr becerra's
record in congress
or in california to suggest he's the
best possible person
to run the department of health and
human services in the middle
of a once in a generation viral pandemic
not even close this is too important a
job at too important
time for this administration to put raw
partisanship ahead
of qualifications so i would strongly
urge all senators to vote against
rescuing this nomination from committee
let's give the president the opportunity
to make a better
selection now mr president on one final
matter as i've mentioned it's customary
for some top senate staff positions to
see new faces
when party control changes hands
today it's my honor to pay tribute to
mary sue jones
a huge asset to this institution has
become
an institution herself tomorrow
mary will finish her second separate run
as assistant secretary of the senate and
conclude a senate career
that has spent more than a quarter of a
century
i first met mary jones in the mid 1990s
when we brought her on board to help
manage my office
neither i nor mary's colleagues back
then could have predicted
that nearly 30 years later she'd depart
as one of the most senior officers
in the entire place but the truth is
if you told us nobody would have been
even a little surprised either
i've entrusted mary with a lot of
different responsibilities over the
years
she served as our office manager just a
few years
out of college she came with me to the
rules committee first his deputy staff
director
and then the top job senator frist had
the good judgment to ask her to be
assistant secretary in the early
2000s then she returned to rules and
resist
resumed serving as our side's staff
director
under senators bob bennett lamar
alexander and then pat roberts
and finally she generously brought all
this expertise and institutional
knowledge back
to the assistant secretary role six
years ago
in her first job in my office mary
organized one team of people
and our infrastructure in her current
job she's overseeing 26 departments
and scores of senate staff pushing
resources and guidance
down and pushing information up
in between it rules she tackled things
like helping run presidential
inaugurations
through it all i cannot name one time
when mary jones
did not deliver she is consistent
competent and completely reliable
no wonder her name has become a kind of
catchphrase around the senate when
anyone's trying to track down some key
piece of wisdom or is puzzling over how
to get
something done well
let's ask mary jones have you checked
with
mary jones i think mary knows
all about that everyone from junior
staff to senior senators
republicans and democrats have been able
to count on mary for expertise
and execution on a million different
subjects
she knows the answer to the question
you're going to ask before you even
finish asking it a rock-solid
administrator
a consummate professional she is
just that good so i'm sorry to see mary
depart the senate but she's given
generously to this place
she certainly earned the opportunity to
apply her many talents to some new
challenges and perhaps knock a few miles
off of her famously epic
commute while she's at it the whole
senate thanks mary for her excellent
service
we wish her her husband and their kids
a little bit in the chat
one thing this is closed a previous
order the senate was
consideration of the motion to discharge
the nomination
of javier becerra from the committee on
senator from oregon president will the
center suspend
yesterday
mr president the senate is demanding
the nomination to distract from the
finance
the nomination of california attorney
general
javier becerra to head the department of
health
and human services as chairman of the
finance committee
i'm going to begin with a simple
message holding up
the nomination of attorney general the
sarah
has been blocking urgent
anti-virus work that needs to get
done now so
it is time for the senate to act
quickly without politics
getting in the way to confirm this
nominee
i also believe mr president moving
quickly on this nomination
will help to achieve something i heard
a lot of senators talk about
over the last few days a few days ago i
spent
almost 24 hours here at
this desk while the senate was debating
a number of different issues over the
course
of that debate and then
many senators talked about how important
it was to get past
some of the long-standing disagreements
and find unity
i will say to my colleagues they're
a more unifying prospect
for america ending
this public health nightmare as quickly
as possible
preventing as many coveted 19 deaths
as possible and helping the american
people get back to the activities
that they enjoy that they consider part
of their normal daily routine
having a confirmed secretary leading the
department of health and human
services is a linchpin for accomplishing
that task the department is
right at the effort at the forefront
to end this contagion it's leading
the addition of vaccines it's working
to get ppe in hands of nurses and
doctors
who still still desperately
need more of it it's getting new
resources to rural hospitals to keep
them
afloat and to keep their doors open to
patients
who literally have nowhere else
to go during this crisis
health and human services is right in
the center
of the government coven response
they coordinate work at the center for
medicare and medicaid
services with the centers for disease
control with the national institutes of
health
with the national guard with all 50
states with the district of columbia
with private health care systems and
doctors across the country
and more individuals and organizations
that are just too numerous to
name now
that's what the job is all about and why
it's so critical
right now and i want to turn to
some of what i've heard
discussed with respect to attorney
general becerra
i've heard some say that well
he doesn't have the right leadership
experience
that's a comment being made about the
head of america's
second largest department of justice
this nominee is in charge of a billion
dollar
budget this nominee is in charge of
more than 4 000
employees the top law enforcement
official
in what would be the fifth largest
economy
in the world this is
work but somebody really knows
how to run a mammoth
from an agency then
there's suggestions
about his healthcare background this is
one that
to me he just
was forgiven his track record he spent
years and years on the house ways and
means committee
which is one of the key committees
in the country with respect to
jurisdiction over health care policy
he wrote and debated major pieces of
health care legislation
including playing an important role
in the development of the affordable
care act as california's attorney
general he defended the affordable care
act in court
when the pandemic hit he stepped up
and fought to protect the health and
well-being
of millions of californians particularly
nurses and doctors and other workers
who found themselves in harm's way
now when you're in the senate
you understand that members of the
opposing party
are going to have disagreements on
policy
issues that goes with the turf
women's health care was obviously one of
those issues
that came up during the nomination
hearing
i will tell you that attorney general
becerra's response
is what we ought to expect of
responsible public officials
and of nominees he made it clear
the members of the finance committee he
said again
and again and again that he will follow
the law
he will be accessible to all senators
he's going to work to find common ground
on key health care
issues and i can tell you having
specialized in healthcare since my days
with the oregon gray panthers
that is heavy lifting and by the way i
think it's
pretty refreshing after four years of
just blather about repeal
and replace and empty rhetoric and
promises on
pharmaceutical price gouging and
partisan policies the favorite insurance
companies over the typical american
consumer
in my view attorney general becerra
proved in his nomination hearing that he
knows
health care policy inside and out
and that he is ready to lead the
department of health and human services
and i don't think anybody ought to be
particularly surprised
because he has got a decades
long track record of health care
leadership and policy experience that's
going to help them succeed in the job
we all understand the country's health
care system
is still under extraordinary
pressure and strain on saturday the
country the senate
passed one of the largest public health
packages
in our country's history designed to
crush this pandemic
so we're starting to see some light
we're starting to see the end of the
tunnel
and the biden administration is doing
everything it can to acquire more
vaccines to get more shocks into arms
i think we all understand it's not
a task completed yet
i'll just close by way of saying that
when our country faces a health care
crisis it needs a secretary
of health and human services confirmed
and on the job as soon as possible it
doesn't need
more political games
and delay that only sets back
our effort to end the pandemic
so we'll be voting i believe in less
than an hour
mr president and i just want to say
that i hope colleagues will support this
nominations discharge from the finance
committee i have known the attorney
general for a number
of years as i say this is the area that
i have specialized
over the years and i know that senators
have differences of opinion
with respect uh to health care
the differences of opinion shouldn't
stand in the way
of a qualified public official
who's managed thousands of people
even in his current job for example
from having the opportunity to do
what has to be done for this country and
that is to get a confirmed nominee
for a critical position so that he can
attack those challenges that are in
front of us right now
and help patients and speed up
speed up the effort to end the pandemic
as president i yield the flaw
the absence of a corner clerk will call
the rule
ms baldwin
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well let me just say this is just what
america needs
uh every eighty percent of americans
will get a check for fourteen hundred
dollars you're a family of four you get
fifty six hundred dollars
that is help that people need so many
people can't feed their kids or might
get out of their homes and even those
who are not that way
more costs for transportation or if you
have a kid in college or schooling
so the fourteen hundred dollars matters
help is on the way
defense secretary for attorney general
for director of national intelligence
for agriculture secretary
and others his candidates were not the
ones that i would have picked if i were
president but i believe it's important
for our country
that our president have a team in place
as long as the president's nominees
aren't raising serious concerns i think
a president either party
is entitled to have the people he or she
chooses serving
in his or her administration
but by the same token if a president's
nominee does raise through his concerns
i think we have a responsibility
as senators to oppose him or her
famous president i rise to oppose the
president's nominee to head the
department of health and human services
a number of president biden's nominees
have been qualified
mainstream candidates javier basara
is not a mainstream candidate he's an
extremist
who has used the offices he has held to
advance an aggressively pro-abortion
agenda
and a target religious liberty and
freedom of conscience
mr basara does not represent the views
of a majority of americans
he represents the views of the radical
pro-abortion wing of the democrat party
mr president the planned parenthood wing
of the democratic party would like to
would like americans to believe that
unrestricted abortion on demand up to
the moment of birth is a no-brainer
an unqualified good but the truth is
despite decades of trying to convince
americans of this
americans simply don't agree just 29
of americans believe that abortion
should be legal in all circumstances
the vast majority of americans believe
that abortion should either be illegal
or that there should be at least some
restrictions
undoubtedly because on some level every
american is aware that when we talk
about abortion we're talking about
killing a human being mr baser on the
other hand does not seem to support
any restrictions on abortion if he does
i would sure like to hear about them
as a congressman he earned perfect
ratings from planned parenthood
and narrow he assembled an
overwhelmingly pro-abortion voting
record even opposing a ban on partial
birth abortion a procedure
so heinous and repulsive it is difficult
to even describe
as california attorney general he
aggressively crusaded
in favor of abortion he's known for
defending california's law forcing
crisis pregnancy centers to advertise
abortion
a case he lost at the supreme court on
first amendment grounds
but his activities were hardly limited
to california abortion law
this was not a case of an attorney
general simply defending the laws of his
own state
no as california attorney general mr
sarah repeatedly
repeatedly inserted himself into
abortion debates in other states
he joined other attorneys general to
file amicus briefs challenging abortion
laws in missouri
arkansas louisiana and other states and
he frequently
led these efforts himself the fact he
proudly highlighted
in press releases mr president mr
becerra's extremist views on abortion
would be enough of a red flag
but to that we have to add mr basara's
record on religious liberty and freedom
of conscience most
famously his efforts to force religious
people
including nuns to offer health insurance
benefits that violate their religious
beliefs
now to finance committee hearing mr
becerra tried to downplay his actions in
this case
i never sued an order of nuns he claimed
i sued the federal government well
that's an
answer only a lawyer could love mr
president
yes he didn't tsunams he sued the
federal government
to force nuns and other religious people
to offer health insurance benefits that
violate
their consciences that was the aim of
his lawsuit mr president
to force nuns and other religious
americans to act
contrary to their consciences
and when an order of nuns the little
sisters of the poor
joined the case in an effort to ensure
their right to live according to their
faith
was protected mr basara apparently had
no hesitation in continuing his suit
mr president mr paser has extremist
views on abortion and his record on
religious liberty
would be troubling in any nominee but
they would matter
a lot less if we were talking about a
nominee for
example say secretary of transportation
that's not what we're talking about
we're talking about putting mr vasari in
charge of a cabinet
but that's not what we're talking about
we're talking about putting mr vasera in
charge of a cabinet department entrusted
with interpreting and applying laws
protecting religious freedom
and freedom of conscience and nothing
i've seen suggested me that mr becerra
can be relied on to provide robust
protection
for these cherished rights in fact
i am profoundly concerned that mr
becerra
would use his office to limit americans
religious freedom under mr bersera's hhs
are nones going to be forced to offer
health insurance benefits that violate
their religious faith
will health care professionals be
protected from having to perform
procedures
like abortions that violate their
consciences
given mr becerra's record i'm concerned
about the answers
to these questions in fact mr president
there's reason to be concerned
that a prime reason for nominating mr
becerra was his radical abortion
advocacy and his
attacks on religious liberty
it's difficult to find another reason
for nominating mr becerra
during a global health emergency
mr baser is not a doctor he's not worked
in the healthcare field
he's not a virologist or a vaccine
expert
he does not have a background in public
health
it's not unreasonable to conclude that
his appeal to the abortion left
one of the most powerful interest groups
in the democrat party
was a prime reason for his nomination
naral planned parenthood certainly gave
credence
to that idea with their enthusiastic
statements in support of mr becerra
which highlighted
his aggressive abortion advocacy
i also have to say that it's pretty
interesting
to nominate someone to head hhs who in
his last
job proudly sued
hhs repeatedly
mr president i know that president biden
is a man of faith
but he is doing a great disservice to
people of faith
and to the first amendment with this
nomination
he's also doing a disservice to the
american people by nominating a
candidate
whose views on abortion are so radical
and so out of step with the views of
most americans
as president days ago three of my
democrat colleagues broke ranks
with their party to stand up for the
many
many americans who don't want their tax
dollars
going to pay for abortions
i urge them and all of my colleagues
to join me in opposing the nomination of
javier
becerra mr president i yield the floor
mr president senator from louisiana mr
president
um we've got an issue in this country
related to the pandemic
but more specifically related to
children not going back to school
and mr president one thing that is of
incredible concern
is it appears that the biden
administration which campaigned
saying that they were going to follow
science alleging that the previous
administration was not seems
not to be following science but to
prejudice their recommendations
to fit a political agenda
with that mr president let me develop my
case the harms of prolonged closure to
school
children's are remarkable they are well
known
it's been up to a year since the schools
have been closed and in mr president's
home state
of california there are some school
systems which are still not reopened
now think about this a place where
children go
not just to learn but to have social
workers make sure they aren't being
abused at home
a dietary staff to make sure they have
adequate nutrition
but also to learn have been closed for a
year
this now now we can say wait a second
don't worry about that because the
children
have been given remote learning there is
ample data mr president which shows
that particularly the children from
lower income families
are not logging on even when they are
given
a broadband computer given a internet
equipped computer to take home
are given wi-fi access to use at home
we can't imagine it mom has to work
there's no one to supervise the child so
the seven-year-old is home by herself
while mom is working we can also imagine
that a a
family does not have a culture of being
online
we can imagine a big family of seven or
eight kids where things just kind of get
lost in the shuffle
and there's not enough room for someone
to be by themselves
whatever it is established that there
are
kids being left behind by not being in
the classroom
and those kids disproportionately are
poor
and that's why the biden
administration's pledged to follow
science resonated and that's why early
indications that they are not is not
just disappointing
it is a betrayal and not a betrayal of a
campaign pledge
a betrayal of those children who are at
home
now by the way data shows that children
can
safely go back to school there was a cdc
study from january of 2021 finding
little evidence
of virus spread in a school setting
when the recommended precautions were
taken
which kind of caused and by the way
there was a recent study
by the following doctors henderson
gandhi hwag and johnson
from universities such as the university
of chicago
uc davis and uc san francisco
showing how safe it is to to go to
school
and not get infected and social
distancing as minimal as
three feet distant one from the other
okay
just three feet distant now that is
important mr president
because if you say you can't bring kids
back to school because you don't have
enough classroom space
for smaller classes it's one thing if
you say there must be six feet between
each child
and another if there only needs to be
three feet
so these doctors from this prestigious
universities found you only needed three
feet
that begs the question of why did the
centers for disease control
in their february 26th document
say that six feet were needed
now you may say six feet three feet why
does it make a difference
because schools aren't reopening and
their excuse is they need six feet
between
students they are finding a reason to
keep kids at home not learning
on a spurious reason the doctors who
wrote this paper
just put an editorial in usa today
and a nice quote here i say nice it kind
of summarizes
it's disappointing that they have to say
this is that
they open up with the only thing we have
to fear is fear itself
which is the quote from the um
franklin roosevelt but go on to say to
speak of the lost wages for families and
the poverty and eviction that this is
resulting in
but the that the research says there are
greater risk to life expectancies with
schools closed
versus schools open but they then ask
that we overcome fear by following the
science
and the science says we can safely
reopen our schools now
full-time non-hybrid and keep them open
unfortunately that is not what the
centers for disease control is saying
now by the way there's a clear agenda
here part of the agenda
is that teachers unions and certain
communities have not wanted to reopen
they're more concerned about the union
than they are
about the children and so whether it is
the democratic mayor
of chicago trying to force the teachers
union into chicago to reopen
whether it is los angeles or san diego
which have still not reopened with
teachers unions
objecting to reopening there not based
upon science
not based upon risk to the teachers of
the children they'd just rather not be
in work
isn't that amazing now let me tell you
who has been open first in louisiana
over over 75 percent of our schools are
reopened hats off to my state
private and parochial schools have been
open
hats off to them kind of the business
model if you don't get paid
you show up for work they show up for
work
uh so so let's get some hats off and
that's why there should be school
choice if a parent can't get their their
child educated in
los angeles in san diego or in chicago
then why are we keeping that child from
going to a private school
oh they can go you say not if they're
poor if they're poor they don't have the
revenue
we should take the money that we're
given to those public schools that will
not open because the teachers unions
oppose it
and give it to the parents so their
children can go to the school
where their children will actually be
educated and the fact that we don't do
that
is politics over
what is best for that child it is a
betrayal
of those children and this
administration's policy four months into
their
into their four years demonstrates
betrayal
after betrayal after betrayal let's
safely reopen schools now we know we can
do so we knew that a year ago
science the data shows it congress has
provided 68 billion dollars
before this latest bill in order to make
sure we had everything we needed
in order to do that um a lack of funding
has not been an excuse to reopen what is
clear is a lack of will and i'll repeat
where i started
this administration is betraying the
most vulnerable
children in our country reopen schools
now
with that i yield the floor
president senator from tennessee
thank you mr president i have to tell
you you can always
tell how controversial a nominee is by
how fast
his supporters work to finish his
confirmation process and last night at 6
12
we found out that the democrats tried to
pull
a fast one on javier basira's nomination
they were trying to fast-track this and
i was able to object to that hotline
request
but the fact that they tried it shows
that they
are worried about this nominee and they
should be
two unimpressive hearings and
seeing the split vote on the finance
committee
and i think my colleagues on the other
side of the aisle have come to realize
that his lack of experience
in the health care sector is one of
those big things you know we have over
400 health care companies in tennessee
and tens of thousands
of employees in that sector they all
each and every one of them have more
health care experience than the biden
administration's
nominee for the secretary of health and
human
services his greatest
hits from his job keep coming back to
haunt him
and as much as his allies here in the
senate try to
spin his record they just can't seem to
convince
people that he is fit to lead
i was curious how wide the divide is
between tennesseans
and the becerra nomination so i asked my
staff to look through
our mailbag and see what people were
calling
and writing about this nomination
was in the top five issues
of concern people in tennessee are not
happy
as i mentioned healthcare our religious
organizations what they are seeing is
somebody who has
crossed the line too many times
they do not see him as fit to lead
his lack of experience in the health
care industry
explains why
so many people would oppose him he
thinks it would be a good idea
to take private health insurance away
from 160 million americans
and throw them into a disastrous
single-payer system if that is what you
want
then he would be a great secretary of
hhs for you
if he has his way he will use his new
position to further
undermine our immigration laws he's
admitted his own
admission mr president that given the
chance
he would decriminalize illegal entry
and extend medicaid benefits to anyone
who managed to make it
across the border it's like winning the
lottery
you get across that border we're going
to give you
health care benefits courtesy of the u.s
taxpayer u.s taxpayer
we cannot afford to keep confirming
nominees who have zero
respect for the rule of law
zero and even less respect
for the value of human life throughout
his career
mr becerra has made his appallingly
radical positions on abortion very
well known he's proud to support
a abortion up until the moment of birth
he
even opposed the 2003
partial birth abortion ban he defended
a truly evil california law that forced
pro-life crisis pregnancy centers
to advertise abortion services offered
by state-run clinics recently
a physician friend of mine made a
comment
about mr becerra's nomination that has
really stuck
with me she said
i'm horrified bear in mind this
is a physician mr president
i'm horrified by his position on
abortion because
he would abort a baby that i
would resuscitate he would abort
a baby that a family is willing
to adopt now think about that
this is a guy
in his congressional career
in his job as the attorney general for
california
he is a radical on abortion
a radical you have physicians who stand
there to resuscitate
these babies have difficulty
during birth he would allow
those babies to be aborted
when a physician would choose would
choose life
would choose to help that baby live
according to mr becerra religious
exemptions should be a thing of the past
he relentlessly harassed religious
employers like hobby lobby
and non-profit organizations like the
little sisters of the poor
as part of his crusade to uphold
obamacare's contraception mandate
i think it's clear why the senate
finance committee split their vote on
this
nomination it has nothing to do with
politics
javier becerra's obsession with
dismantling american society
and rebuilding it in his own image
can't be boiled down to a simple policy
position
instead it signals his desire to force
americans to live their lives
according to his twisted
world view he may have the approval
of leftists but the american people
and thousands of tennesseans have
already written him
off as radically unqualified
and frankly so have i i urge my
colleagues
to join me in opposing this motion to
discharge
and opposing the nomination he is
radically anti-life
anti-religion anti-border security
anti-free speech he is unqualified to
lead
i yell the floor
mr president senator from montana
mr president montana has a rich outdoor
heritage
it's something we're known for not just
across the country but
even around the world there's something
as montanans we're very proud of
in fact for generations montana families
have enjoyed hunting fishing
recreating on public lands i myself an
avid outdoorsman in fact some of my
fondest memories growing up in montana
are spending time with my family with my
dad my mom
my grandpa hunting fishing backpacking
in our state
and thankfully i've had a chance to pass
it on to
our own four children something we still
enjoy doing today
my wife and i we're now empty nesters
recreation on public lands is part of
our montana way of life
it's how we raise our families in
montana
and just as we cherish our access to our
public lands
we also value the conservation
of our lands as well as the stewardship
of our vast natural resources energy
development
flourishes in montana it provides over
16
000 hard working men and women with good
paying jobs
to support their families while funding
conservation and protecting our
landscapes and wildlife montana is still
a state
where hard-working moms and dads they
work hard during the week
thankful for many jobs provided by the
natural resources in our state
they work hard during the week but on
the weekends they go down to walmart
bob ward sportsman's warehouse any
sporting goods store
and buy an elk tag over the counter a
fishing license
and get into our public lands within 30
minutes of buying that license that's
uniquely part of our montana experience
these jobs that we have in the natural
resource industry these energy jobs
are part of who we are as montanans
because we're a state full of diverse
interests competing priorities sometimes
opposing philosophies
but time and time again stakeholders
have come together
to find balance and achieve our most
lasting
conservation wins
that's a word that's missing in
washington dc
as we're seeing the new administration
come to power it's the word
balance you see as montanans we're proud
stewards of our beautiful landscapes our
rivers our natural resources and our
wildlife
we take pride in following the science
and listening to our local experts on
the ground
to do what's best for our environment
and our public lands as well as our
rural communities
and this legacy of bounds is intertwined
within the jurisdiction
of the department of interior because
the secretary
of the interior oversees much of
america's lands
our water wildlife energy resources
they many way many ways oversee our
montana way of life
over the past few years we've seen
secretaries of the interior with a range
of views some i agree with some i
haven't
but one thing was consistent they were
consensus builders
they were able to listen to the needs of
diverse stakeholders
bring folks together come up with a
solution that works for most everybody i
would use the word
balance again unfortunately
representative holland
has a very well documented and hostile
record
toward made in america energy toward
natural resource development
towards wildlife management in sportsmen
throughout her tenure as a congresswoman
representative holland
championed the green new deal she
advocated for the most
extreme positions including
banning all fossil fuels
she co-sponsored legislation to provide
federal protections
for grizzly bears forever
without considering the science that's
very clear
that supports delisting that species
and returning it back to the states just
like we did with wolves back in 2011.
she's been enthusiastic in her calls to
stop
not just the keystone pipeline but all
pipelines calling for ban for all
pipelines she even protested
the dakota access pipeline herself
she has stated that trapping shouldn't
be allowed
on public lands and as noted by several
sportsmen groups representative holland
would not even commit to maintaining
current access on our public lands
during the hearing
i can tell you these are not mainstream
views
held by most montanans
i'm not opposed to representative
holland's confirmation because she's a
democrat
or because she was nominated by
president biden
in fact i've supported many of the
president's nominees
this is about her record her very
far left divisive positions
that will fail to represent the west to
be in the mainstream
of common sense and balance and fear she
will harm the montana way of life
as we nut this is about protecting
our montana way of life the ability to
have a good paying job
during the week and enjoying our public
land on the weekends
because you kill the energy jobs you
kill all the pipelines you kill
natural resources montana is left to be
simply a playground for the rich and
famous
we've got to stand up for hard-working
montanans
and protect their way of life
this is about maintaining a common sense
balance we can
develop our natural resources and
protect
our public lands at the same time
we can do both and we must do both
so i urge my colleagues especially those
from western states
that hold many of these same values to
really think about
what representative holland would bring
to the department of interior
as leader of that organization
i urge my colleagues to consider the
impact this will have
and to vote against representative
holland's nomination
for secretary of the interior mr
president yield back my time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
is
[Music]
[Music]
though
[Music]
um
you'll see a lot of photographers
there's a lot of reporters down here
you know oh yeah
all right
while you're up there
you good cool
[Music]
it's kind of good
gators are coming back
[Music]
we actually did a cicada story with lisa
myers
okay
i'm not